the famous american writer ursula le
guin
expresses her own thoughts through a
character in her book in these lines
the word must be heard in silence there
must be darkness to see the stars
the phrase has to do with the birth and
death of all that exists
every object in the universe has its
beginning and its end
some subatomic particles last as little
as tenths of a second
some microorganisms live between two
hours and several days
man's life expectancy counts several
decades
but even stars eventually burn out after
millions and billions of years of
existence
and what about the universe itself is it
also going to come to an end at some
point
what will it be like and what will
happen
after its death
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
the earliest theory of the genesis of
our world is what is known as theory
of the stationary universe or steady
state universe
supporters of this theory claim that the
universe has no beginning and no end
it has always been and always will be in
its steady state of equilibrium
however very soon scientific estimations
proved this theory likely to be wrong
as there are some irreversible processes
taking place in the universe
in the 1910s and 1920s the big bang
theory was formulated
and widely popularized today
it is one of the most consistent
scientific theories
and it is able to account for the
universe's genesis and evolution
dozens of scientists contributed to the
development of the big bang theory
and albert einstein's works on the
general theory of relativity
laid the theories foundation the main
conclusion this theory enabled
scientists to arrive at
is the supposition that the fate of the
universe depends on dark energy
a theoretical type of energy causing
space to expand
be it as it may at this point it is
quite impossible to say anything
definite about this physical phenomenon
there are a great number of theories
about this and each of them has its
praiseworthy aspects and shortcomings
according to data we possess today the
age of the universe is calculated from
the moment of the big bang
and is estimated it's slightly less than
14 billion years the universe is
constantly expanding
and depending on the density of dark
energy it will either expand forever
at a regularly increasing rate or else
the expansion will slow down
and reverse in this case the universe is
bound to compress
into an infinitely small singularity
similar to what it originated from
today science is not ready to give a
definite answer to the question
which of these two possibilities will
prevail
however it is ready to suggest at least
two equally possible scenarios of what
may happen next
referred to as the big rip and the big
crunch
the universe's expansion rate is
proportional to distances between
objects
the further some objects are located
from each other the higher the expansion
rate
imagine a balloon pumped with air there
are two dots on it
if we pump still more air into the
balloon the dots will get further away
from each other
that's the way the expansion of the
universe works it is space itself that
expands
the further the dots are initially
located the faster they get
still further apart at a certain point
this rate exceeds the speed of light
this point is known as the event horizon
all objects beyond it disappear from
view and they drift away beyond the
reach of the most advanced telescopes
never to be observed again
just imagine first the remotest galaxies
and clusters will disappear from the sky
then one by one the milky way stars will
fade away
and to crown it all it will be the turn
for our sun to go
dim what a gloomy sight
if the big rip theory holds good the
universe's expansion rate will be
constantly on the increase
this will lead to expansion forces
gradually overcoming gravity forces
following that first galaxy clusters and
then galaxies themselves and star
clusters will be broken up
after that it will be the turn for
stellar systems to disintegrate
as host stars will not have sufficient
pool to keep their planets and
satellites from floating away
at the next stage matter will be reduced
to atoms and these will be reduced to
subatomic particles matter will
effectively cease to exist
after this physical laws as we know them
will cease to be
and any further developments are quite
impossible to predict
observations today show that space
expands and the expansion rate is on the
increase
however we're not familiar with the
nature of dark energy
it may well have properties unknown to
us at this point
and these may reverse the expansion
processes
as a result the universe will start
contracting
this may well happen if general
gravitation created by all matter in the
universe
exceeds its expansion force this
scenario is what is known as the big
crunch in this case processes in the
universe will run in the same manner
until its size decreases five times
galaxy clusters will come together as
one supercluster
which in essence will fill the entire
universe considerably shrunk by this
point
meanwhile inside the galaxies events
like births and deaths of stars
planet formation and so on will keep
taking place
just like before when the universe
contracts 20 times more
its volume will account for just one
percent of that of today's
and all galaxies will blend into one the
relic radiation temperature by that time
will measure 274 degrees
kelvin and it will still continue to
grow
this means that there won't be any
liquid water left in the universe
and water is vital for biological life
as we know it
further contraction of space will cause
the universe to heat up even more
planets will first be burnt and then
melted
all matter will crumple into an enormous
cloud of boiling plasma
after that atoms and subatomic particles
will disperse
and eventually the universe will
collapse into a singularity
similar to the one it used to be when it
was born
there is a theory which is a kind of a
spin-off of the big crunch theory
it is known as the big bounce theory
according to the big bounce theory
on reaching the state of singularity
following the big crunch
the universe will be reborn as a result
of yet another big bang
and the cycle will repeat itself again
and again supposedly forever
as far as it is possible to speak about
eternity and conditions
devoid of time and space i will repeat
myself yet again by saying that our
knowledge about dark energy is too
meager to speak about the duration
of any of these scenarios for all we
know
the next big rip or big crunch for that
matter will take place in a period when
there are still stars and planets around
but what if it isn't the case what will
happen to the universe
if its ultimate fate is still extremely
remote in time
still the laws of physics imply that the
universe as we more or less know it
cannot exist forever there are four
clearly defined epochs in cosmology
and each of them is associated with this
or that particular phenomenon
we live in the so-called stelliferous
era there is a lot of interstellar gas
in the parts of the universe around us
it is used as raw material for stars to
form from
and used stars are born from this gas
and the process will continue until all
interstellar gas has been depleted
this sea park is expected to be over in
the period from 1 to 100 trillion years
from now
by that time the sun and the
overwhelming majority of other stars
will have depleted their nuclear fuel
subsequently turning into white dwarfs
neutron stars or black holes
i've actually already spoken about it in
an earlier video
the next era is known as the degenerate
era
there will not be any main sequence
stars around anymore
most mata in the universe will remain in
the form of white and brown dwarves and
some mata will persist as neutron stars
and black holes
it will take a great amount of time for
all these objects to cool off
around a duodecillion or 10 to the power
of 39 years
white dwarfs will gradually give off
their heat in the form of radiation
and become black dwarves as for brown
dwarfs they will cool off too
thermonuclear reactions taking place in
their interior at a sluggish rate will
eventually stop completely
gradually most matter will be slurped by
black holes
at this stage of the universe's
evolution dark matter annihilation and
protons disintegration will be the major
processes
the proton is a subatomic particle that
atoms known to science are built of
it is considered one of the most durable
subatomic particles
its life expectancy as it were accounts
for approximately a hundred geodesian
or 10 to the power of 41 years
now by the time this sierra comes to an
end mata in the universe will look like
a great ocean of freely floating
elementary particles with an occasional
neutron star or black hole tucked away
among them
the next era is the black hole era
according to some theories black holes
will form clusters and eventually blend
together
thus forming one single gargantuan black
hole
alternative theories suggest that black
holes will slowly evaporate while
emitting energy
before vanishing completely black hole
evaporation is a quantum effect
produced by what is known as hawking
radiation the smaller hole
the more intense of its evaporation
which eventually strips the whole of all
its matter and energy
this process is supposed to persist for
10 to the power of 100 years
this number is also referred to as
google
be it as it may eventually only dead
expanses of space
will be left in the universe this space
will contain debris left over from
processes having taken place in the
previous sea parks
photons electrons positrons neutrinos
and quarks
electrons and positrons will collide
thus causing annihilation
the universe may exist in this state
practically forever
until the next big crunch or big grip at
the very least
either way the humanity will be long
gone at that time
its existence is likely to be terminated
in the stelliferous era
our planet meanwhile will remain
habitable for another billion years or
so
and after that it will be burned by the
ever-intensifying glow of the sun
about five or six billion years later
our sun
by then a red giant will shed its outer
layers and become
a white dwarf but what will happen after
the universe dies
disappointing as it is there is
absolutely no way we can answer this
question
the trouble is whatever the scenario
there won't be either time or space
as we know them even if the big bounce
theory or the big crunch theory is right
or else a new big bang takes place thus
giving birth to a new universe with a
fresh set of galaxies and stars
we will simply never find out just like
we will never find
out what it used to be like in the
universe before
hours because the word must be heard in
silence
there must be darkness to see the stars
feel free to express your opinion leave
a comment under the video or just hit
the like button
if you're inquiring minds grave for more
exciting stuff on our channel you're
welcome to subscribe
your support really means a lot to us
and motivates us to produce still more
videos for you to enjoy
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you